في ذكرى نكسه حزيران السادسه والخمسين
مظاهر الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والاستيطاني
جاثمه على تفاصيل حياه الفلسطينيين
جابر دبابسن شاب دفعه الاحتلال الى العيش
مع عائلته الصغيره في مغاره تعود لقرون
مضت وخيمه على انقاض بيته في خله الضبع
بمسافه جنوب شرقي مدينه الخليل
الاحتلال هدم بيته خمس مرات جربنا الهدم
وعشنا الهدم يعني لو اقتلعوا الاشجار زي
ما بيهددوا وما تبقى من بيوت كما لو هدموه
لو هدموا المغر احنا في الاخر هاي ارضنا
ما فيش بديل صراحه يعني ما فيش بديل هاي
الاراضي استورثناها عن جدودنا
نحو 20500 فلسطيني يعيشون في اثني عشر
تجمعا مهددون بالطرد وهدم بيوتهم لان
سلطات الاحتلال تعتبرها منطقه عسكريه لكن
هذا لم يمنع المستوطنين من اقامه الست بؤر
لهم تضاف الى نحو 10 مستوطنات تحيط بمسافه
وتضيق الحياه على الفلسطينيين
المستوطن بصير يتهدد فيه بجيب الجيش بقول
له هذا
بس يطلع من هان
هذا مش كله الي زرع في اشي معاي لابن عمي
ولكن ما حدا سامع لصوت ولا حدا حسبي الله
ونعم الوكيل المؤسسات الرسميه ولجانو
العمل الشعبي ترى ان ما يجري في مسافه يطا
مقدمه لترسيخ الاستيطان في عموم الاراضي
الفلسطينيه هو مخطط استيطاني جديد يسعى
اليه الاحتلال من خلال ذلك المخطط الكبير
الذي يربط المناطق الشمال بمناطق الجنوب
هؤلاء المستوطنين الرعاه يعني شكل جديد من
اشكال الاستعمار والاسبان والسيطره على
مزيد من الاراضي كما يحدث حاليا في منطقه
مسافر يطا
منذ النكسه وحتى اليوم اقام الاحتلال اكثر
من 300 واربعين مستوطنه في بقيه اراضي
الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله خصوصا
المناطق المصنفه جيم وفي الاونه الاخيره
قررت الحكومه الاسرائيليه الغاء قانون فك
الارتباط عن المستوطنات شمال الضفه
الغربيه ومنها بؤره حومش الاستيطانيه شمال
نابلس فعادت اليها الجمعيات الاستيطانيه
المتطرفه سياسه تهجير سكان الاصليين في
هذه القرى المهدده بالهدم تعيد مشهد
احتلال الاراضي الفلسطينيه منذ اكثر من 50
عاما فهي سياسه اصبحت ورقه رابحه بين يدي
حكومه نتنياهو الحاليه التي تستند في
استمرار توليفتها على تلبيه مطامع
المستوطنين في توسيع مشاريعهم على حساب حق
الفلسطيني في ارضه
سمير ابو شمالي الجزيره الخليل فلسطين